m
[Musique]
ramasser les déchets dans la rue une
passion pour elliott depuis ses deux ans
du haut de ses quatre pattes ce labrador
traque les détritus lors de ses balades
quotidiennes
c'est venu des armes en tant qu il a
commencé par une bouteille il ya
quelques années en plus ça a continué en
s'aggravant si on peut dire ça grave on
en ramasse en plus de choses et pour lui
c'est une passion maintenant tous les
jours de ramasser le maximum de choses
et de les ramener
bouteilles en plastique emballages pizza
ou paquets de cigarettes vides tant
qu'il peut attraper elliott récupère
tous et pas question d'abandonner son
trésor sur le chemin est un rituel il va
s'arrêter normalement devant le
conteneur et devant le contenir il va
tout lâcher là je peux vous montrer
qu'il lâchera pas tu peux toujours et
s'étirer en aucune façon il a trois
choses qu'il a tout prévu et fait
qu'arriver à la maison qui va accepter
tout lâcher pour avoir
un comportement écologique qui attise la
curiosité à 7 ans l'animal est devenu
une star dans le quartier ça assez
intelligent à neutre notre notre chien
là du voisin je pense que c'est une
bonne chose mais bon c'est dommage que
des gens aient jamais chose comme ça
dans la rue c'est pas bien elliott y
sera contraint est un chien quand même
que les gens y font n'importe quoi voit
tous les jours elliott accompagne
également son mettre au travail dans le
cadre de la police de l'eau cette ruche
n'a pas fini de nettoyer nos allées
[Musique]